this is a joint work with Ravi cannon
and David in case you didn't get the
impression from from the last talked he
works on algorithms to okay
right cloud computing so yeah I haven't
actually computed on a cloud so far but
apparent I'm you do a Google search
aren't you computing on the on the cards
so we all we're all doing it well I
guess the main point is that data is
distributed on many servers and you know
this is not a this is not a new thing
this has been happening for a while in
you know in parallel algorithms
computation is distributed and there the
focus is somehow the time the time to
complete the task in streaming
algorithms again there's so much data
that doesn't even fit in memory and not
even on on many processors or many
servers but they're the focus is sub
linear space or memory and so I guess in
cloud the many servers the in addition
to time and space you want for the
question is communication so that's the
bottlenecks I guess that motivation is
something like they've all these servers
sitting out there their data pieces of
the data you're computing some function
of the entire set of data and you'd like
to compute this function with as little
communication as possible you measure
the total amount of communication
because that's the bottom line you know
each each bit you're sending is has some
latency and bandwidth so takes up more
time so in any case it's it's a resource
you have to grapple okay so this this
sort of consideration was introduced in
this in a paper by korma demote
efficient and ye in 2008 and so what
we're calling here and nimble algorithm
is one that has polynomial time in space
as usual but but ideally it also has sub
linear communication right so the
communication time is yeah is much
smaller than the size the data so you
don't want a solution where you're
saying let's just send all the data to
server one compute the answer and you're
done so we want to sublet you somehow
you're avoiding that ok now it's there's
a there's actually a natural connection
between this sort of
model where you have distributed data
and you would like to minimize
communication and streaming where data
is just coming through in a stream and
you want to keep your memory small your
space small the swimming algorithms as
we saw in in the first talk today keep
small sketches of data that's the key
thing in fact as far as i know all
streaming algorithms are sketching
algorithms no ok ok so the ones i know
are all sketching algorithms and they
you know so you can always run a
streaming out a sketching algorithm in
the cloud by saying i'll computer sketch
each server computes a sketch of its of
its data and pass us on the sketch to
the second server computes its sketch of
its data maybe uses the first sketch and
good moves on now maybe they all just
compute sketches share their sketches
and everybody computes a function of all
the sketches so this is something you
could always do now nimble algorithms
the ones that must use little
communication somehow must also compute
some kind of summary of the data since
they are not sending the whole data and
there's a question are they equivalent
can you actually do things more
efficiently you seem to have more power
because you can each server can do
whatever it wants on its data set it has
all of it in memory on its subset of
data so there's simple observation in a
paper by dumb Phillips AHA encrypted
subramanyam that says that the total
communication in the cloud is never more
than the order of the memory you use in
the streaming model just because you
could do this business of passing along
the sketches yes so for now we're
assuming that there's already been an
arbitrary partition a completely
arbitrary partition has been made so
data has been collected on these servers
by some distributed process and it's
it's so we think of it as an arbitrary
partition of the year it might be
interesting to consider some more
careful partition or random partition
but for now we're taking the worst case
approach that it has been so customer
preferences have been aggregated by
servers based on some hard to discern
process
no no the data is already sitting there
so that's collected over time separately
so is this so can you do something
better or faster then then then then in
the streaming model what are the limits
so what we should talk about a set of
problems to think about so here are
problems that touch on this stock the
computing frequency moments it's a basic
problem for large data sets that comes
up a lot and was one of the foundational
problems for the streaming model
counting copies of sub graphs so you
want to count how many triangles or how
many see force people use this in
clustering to try to get a sense of how
non-random some data might be low-rank
approximation or computing the top
principal components or the subspace of
the top k principal components
clustering and so those are the ones
we'll talk about it in this in the next
half an hour but you could also talk
about other problems you know you want
to compute a an approximate maximum
matching or a flow or solve a linear
program where the constraint matrix has
been distributed somehow or the entries
of the constraint matrix have been
distributed and these are things where I
don't have anything interesting to say
ok so for for this for these first four
problems there are already nice results
in streaming and be more or less know
the picture of the upper bound versus
lower bound for how much space is needed
so let's go with the first problem
frequency moments so you're given a
vector of frequencies so these are
frequencies of items and you might not
actually have the vector itself they
might just come as updates so you see a
sequence of item i plus 1 item J plus 1
or could be minus also in the module
model and these correspond at the end of
the day too if you aggregate them set of
frequencies and you'd like to compute
the chaos norm I should really put to
the power of K on the left there but the
sum of the cape hours of these
frequencies that's what you want to
compute I don't exactly know why you
want to compute this beyond k equal to 2
but apparently it's of interest in in
databases and it seems like a like a
nice thing to compute to within small
relative
now a foundational result of alone
mathiasen sogeti showed that 4k less
than equal to 2 you can use a small
space random projection limited
independence random projection to
compute this to arbitrary accuracy ok no
now this was tightened by Indian
woodruff and there were some papers in
between so now we know that the bound
for space in the streaming model is n to
the 1 minus 2 or K and up to log factors
this is both the upper bound and the
lower bound so for k equal to 3 say you
get a polynomial lower bound on the
space so you need a n to the one third
space to we will say get a factor two
approximation to the to the to the two
to the third third norm and then that
gets higher a closely related problem
well we'll see why it's related counting
counting various things these already
have a quadratic lower bound basically
need to see almost the entire graphs
before you can count the number of
triangles to with the num within say
factor of two ok now for low-rank
approximation what is the problem you
have a matrix n by D and you'd like to
find another matrix but of rank at most
K or equal to K so that the let's say
the Frobenius norm is at most 1 plus
epsilon times what you'd get if you had
the best pranky approximation which i
have denoted as AK here so there is the
best approximation and you want to be
within 1 plus epsilon so usual low-rank
approximation and for this Clarkson and
woodruff showed that any swimming
algorithm needs linear space essentially
well not quite linear it's n plus D
times K right so if you want to get that
approximation you need this and there's
a / i'm ignoring the dependence of
epsilon let's say factor of two you need
this much space already ok
okay so so for all so I haven't said
anything about clustering here but for
the for the first three problems
frequency moments homomorphisms and
low-rank approximation in streaming you
already have sorry linear lower bounds a
linear in at least and the number of
items or number of rows so that's all
you would get if you try to apply
blindly or black box reduction of cloud
of server computation to streaming so we
have to do something different if you
want to do better and first well is it
even clearer that you can do better so
let's look at a lower bar so the lower
bounds for streaming are typically or
most of them I won't say mall or come
from this problem called set disjoint
nests or multiplayer set this join us
the T players and they have subsets of
of 1 through n and the problem is let's
say to determine whether the sets are
all disjoint or all have a one element
in common that's just that's one case of
this there are various cases that are
interesting you just want to determine
are they all dis joint or do they all
have one element in common how many bits
do you need to communicate and so up
through a series of papers we know now
that you need at least n over roughly n
over T bits to determine this you need
at least n over T bits ok so it's the
subsets of 1 through n and to determine
if there's one element in common versus
none you already need n over T bits
total communication now let's look at so
that's the theorem the same thing let's
now let's take for the case of computing
of frequency moments you know the sets
are as I said either disjoint or one
element in common let's think of each
set that is being on one server right
each subset of one through n is on one
server and the function you are trying
to compute is 0 if they're all disjoint
and one if they all have one element in
common now look at what the cat
frequency moment will be the way we'll
do it is we'll just compute the K at
frequency moment and see if it's small
or large if they had nothing in common
then the frequency moment would be just
some of 1 to the K which is n if they
had one element in common it would be n
minus 1 plus that one element would have
frequency s so it's s to the K right so
you have a big ratio
between n and n minus 1 plus s to the K
so suppose we have a factor two
approximation for the keith frequency
moment then we can set as to the k to be
say n plus 1 and you are able to
distinguish between these two cases you
can solve this problem of telling set
disjointed so factor two approximation I
can do this but we know that there's a
lower bound of n over T which is n over
s in this case n is s to the K that's a
lower bound of s to the K minus 1 so if
you want to compute the kid frequency
moment on s servers you need at least s
to the K minus 1 bits that just follows
them but that's all only as to the K
minus 1 not n to the 1 minus 2 over K
okay so it's in particular if you add
let's say the number of servers was not
a function of n the total number of size
of database this is some constant okay
so what what can the upper bound be so
what will prove here is that the kid
frequency moment on s servers you can do
using just s to the K over epsilon
squared words of communication where
each word is B plus log N and B is the
word length of the of the input
frequencies okay so so yeah so compared
to the lower bound this is a factor of s
times number of bits used per word
higher previously woodruff and Zhang had
a bound of s to the K minus 1 times poly
log in I mean a polynomial in log n over
epsilon where the exponent depended on K
and as I mentioned the streaming complex
the lower bound is much higher now the
main idea of the algorithm is going to
be very simple algorithm the idea will
be to sample elements according to their
powers of their frequencies now we've
seen already through yesterday and most
of you know that sampling rose a rose of
a matrix or elements for stream
according to their squared values or
according to leverage scores which is a
square in a different basis is very
useful here it will turn out that you
need you need higher powers and gives
you gives you a lot of flexibility so
it's to do a simple very simple exercise
before we do that there's a simplest
case where this is interesting all
ready is when you have two servers and
you want to compute the third moment
okay so third moment is already hard for
streaming polynomial space hard so here
we have Butthead I mean it needs
polynomial space not piece plays hard
and then you hear you need let's see
what we need two servers and let's say
the frequencies on the first server are
you one through you and the frequencies
on the second server we won through we
end so these are the aggregates of the
updates that these servers have received
their non-negative and with what we'd
like to compute is the sum of UI plus VI
cube right that's that's that's what you
wanna complete okay so let's expand it
you know when you expand it I should
have written down the expansion there's
a UI cubed term which is easy you do it
in one server VI cube done that's easy
dude on the other server and it's the
cross terms you have to worry about now
the crops terms look like what you i
squared V VI and VI square do I so we'll
do those two separately okay so how are
we going to do the some of you i squared
VI that's what we want to do where the
user on one server these are none of the
server okay so here's what we'll do
we'll sample an element the first server
will sample an element with probability
proportional to its third power okay so
at least you're computing third moment
third power it's nothing crazy and then
it announces the this index J and then
the other server will compute what we
want u J squared V J but / PJ this
probability so it announces J and the
probability okay and so that will let
that will compute this number and we
average this over 1 over epsilon squared
samples now the point is that the
expectation of this variable that's
being computed is exactly what you want
right because it's with probability P J
we're computing UJ square x VG so it's
it has the right expectation the
question is what's the variance that's a
fairly straightforward computation too
so there's the probability there is a
random variable now it's only that if
it's if in fact we yeah and there's the
expectation and for the variance i'm
just literally bounding it by the second
moment
so the sum is only over V is that are
positive it's the sum of x squared times
P I 1p I cancels and then you get you
know the p.i has the UI cube in the
denominator that goes up and you're left
there the last percept I just use the
inequality that you I VI squared is
always smaller than either you I cube or
VI q so that's it straight forward the
right thing and that's the variance and
this variance is perfectly fine for us
because the quantity we are estimating
is exactly summation of UI q plus VI q
so the standard deviation is of the
right order in fact you need only one
over epsilon squared samples for two
servers third moment okay so that's the
total communication that x log okay so
now let's do many servers k at moments
is the general problem you have s
servers and you want to compute the cat
moment so that's the expression you want
a computer right now f IJ stands for the
frequency of the I element on the jet
server right so server can aggregate its
updates f IJ is how many times the jet
server saw the i8 element okay and so
the total frequency of the light element
is the inner some there we're powering
that 2k and adding it up over all n
elements that's that's what you light
computer okay so now I'm just expanding
out that that power there and you get
here k choose r1 through RS which add up
to k so that you it's the number of
power so how many times you take fi fi
one how many times you take fi two and
so on and then you're left with f IJ to
the rj right so that's just expansion of
the of that now let's reverse the
summations so that we will do one
estimation of for each term of this type
so there are at most s to the K terms
that the s to the K and now we need to
estimate a term of this type which is
what the sum over all elements of the
product of the frequencies to the power
of RJ for a fixed set of rj c r 1 r 2 up
to some RR
RM or are what I call it s and you want
the product of f IJ to the RJ summed up
over all elements that's what you want
okay so we'll do that separately so this
is the goal now fix one of those terms
you want to estimate that okay now this
is a little bit trickier right because
because yeah so the first server again
samples an element with probability now
proportional to the cat moment it always
fixed the cat moment for the so the cat
power of the frequency so that's just
that's all it is look at what it has
power everybody to the power of K pick
one according to the cat power okay now
it sends this to to everybody you know
every other server J Prime has to it's
going to make a decision it either
announces the frequency of that element
I in its set or it doesn't and it sense
it either no this is just breaking ties
either if you know it's index is smaller
than the index of the server that's
sending this element and its value is
smaller so in in all cases it only
outputs its frequency if the frequency
if its frequency is smaller than the
lead for this round of the computation
so server J is leading this round we're
going to do this for every server
several J is leading this round so in
that term server J is going to be
responsible for all terms in which f IJ
is the highest okay all eyes where f IJ
is highest so everybody else once they
know f IJ they know whether they're
higher or lower and the only announce
themselves if they are lower and this
business of j prime less than J and J
prime greater than J with less than
equal to just to break ties so that we
don't have people sending it both ways
you could do that in a couple of ways
okay once you've done that now server J
which was leading this computation has
all the frequencies for the index I and
it it knows the powers RJ that that's
that that's what this whole routine is
doing right now and it estimates the
correct term divided by the probability
with which you
come up with that term ok so again so
this is the entire algorithm again for
that term so the expectation is correct
by design I mean we do a divided by P I
so the expectation is correct but the
variance is once again small it's at
most basically the quantity we are
computing okay so this takes a little
bit more computation but also is
straightforward so and then the so
therefore to estimate one term you only
again need only one over epsilon squared
samples the total number of terms is s
to the K at most so the computation
times s to the K over epsilon square so
it's a very simple algorithm the only
new trick or element is that you need to
sample according to a higher power of
the frequency okay and you achieve
nearly optimal communication so the next
problem close related to this it is
counting copies of a graph one graph in
another so we think of the graph H as a
fixed graph I'm thinking or fixed size
you want to know how many copies of this
are there in some big graph G now the
big graph G is distributed it's all over
the place it's on some vertices having
this where server somewhere is in this
server and so on and nevertheless you
would like to figure out how many copies
so for example some interesting cases
that have come up in various
applications are a number of triangles
number of four cycles you know number of
complete bipartite say r by r sub graphs
and so on and there are linear lower
bounds for for all these things in this
framing one now even in the cloud model
you get lower bounds of Omega n safe for
counting triangles for counting four
cycles so even in this model here you
can't beat sub linear in n if it's a
graph with n vertices and that's using
the same multi-party said this join us
lower bound so I won't go with that but
the old bound of n is impossible to
avoid if we assume an arbitrary
partition of the edges of the graph if
the edges have been spotted in orbit
early then then you can't avoid this one
no god but what we will do instead is
suppose we assume a partition of the
vertices which is arguably natural for
many applications that the vertices of
the graph
so everybody has the adjacency list of
some vertices of the graph which word is
this that's arbitrary but it's you get
the entire row of the adjacency matrix
under this setting you can do some
things so for example suppose you wanted
to count the number of paths of length
to where the graph has degrees d 1
through DN so this is one way to write
number for more prisms the number of
copies of k-12 that's the graph path of
length 2 in the graph g is just the
summation of di choose to because the
center vertex is I it has to pick two of
its neighbors that's a path of length 2
that's day I choose to and you're adding
in upper overall I vertices now that's
just a polynomial right it's the second
frequency moment minus the first you
know summation of di you get in terms of
di square and di both of which we can
estimate in fact you could have done
this in the streaming model also because
these are just second moments but now
we'll get interesting if we go consider
a graph which has a bigger power
polynomial with a bigger power so
suppose I consider the number of stars
one are so star with our leaves then
this is just summation of di choose our
and that we can now do just simply by
using the frequency counting algorithm
from the previous from the from the
earlier part of from either i just
described number of c4s well for the
number of c4 so number four cycles right
we pick two vertices and let's define
dij as the number of common neighbors of
a pair of vertices and then the number
of see force is d IJ choose to because
you comment you have to pick two pairs
of common neighbors a pair of common
errors and similarly if you want to do
complete sub graphs of with a cross B
you can do that as define the common
degree of a subset of vertices ds4 a
subset of vertices d s is the number of
vertices they have all have as a common
neighbor and that choose B gives you the
number of
bipartite graphs a cross P so there is
no new algorithm here it's just saying
that when you have a partition of rows
in the cloud model you can just use
frequency moments to count number of
copies of a sub graph okay so next I'll
go to yes I know there are many graphs
which of so I didn't put triangles here
noticeably and four triangles sorry part
of length 3 I don't know actually there
is a class of graphs we can do the
theorem is in the paper where if all the
degrees of the vertices come from a
fixed subset of possible degree numbers
that's what we can do but it's not like
saying vertex one has this degree in
vertex to it each vertex can have any
one of these degrees count all graphs
with this property that's what you can
reduce directly lady but there could
very well be some other more thoughtful
algorithm here okay any other person so
next we go to low-rank approximation or
approximating the top-k SVD subspace so
that's the problem again but now the
data right the matrix a is your data
that's the full data set and it's been
partitioned among the servers as
matrices so the the entries I mean they
just add up to the right matrix it could
be that each one you have some subset of
the entries or even each entry has been
split up somehow doesn't matter the
whole point that all you want to do is
compute a function of the sum of the
matrices that have been stored on
separate servers ok so maybe these are
these user recommendations or likes or
something and each server is collecting
some things and you want a computer one
function of the entire entire matrix
yeah it's an N by D matrix now M
it seems like you need a linear
communication because your answer is of
size you know your computing a matrix at
the end of the day and you want that
matrix to sit somewhere it seems that
you need some kind of linear
communication if you want to really
output that matrix so what we'll say
instead is that this matrix itself will
be partitioned among the servers okay so
each server it has a 1 it will compute a
1 tilde it has a 2 it will compute a 2
tilde with the property that the sum of
the AIS is of course the original data a
the sum of the AI Tilda's will be a rank
K and a good approximation to a ok so
each one will get a good approximation
to its part of the data but good
approximation in the sense that it's
actually a good approximation to the
whole matrix you could have computed
Grand Cay approximation to its own data
without any communication yes
AK is the best rank approximation sorry
oh I excuse me in case that prevents you
from paying for their attentions let's
call it um okay
right okay so that's the best ranked
approximation and yeah so we want to
find places locally so now at least
there is not that isn't the trivial
lower bound where you where you say oh
look you had even communicating the
answer would have taken this time this
much time in principle it might need
very little communication so that's the
problem how do we compute these
approximate parentheses inside each one
so that their sum is a true truly good
ranking approximation ok now we're
thinking so this is the theorem that you
can actually do it for an N by D matrix
with total communication that's only skd
SS number of servers k is the rank and d
is the shorter dimension ok so if it's
an N by D matrix will need skd but it's
an arbitrary partition not a row
partition go back to arbitrary partition
of the day ok and it seems that skd
might be a lower bound but we haven't
pinned that down completely skd might
actually be a lower bound even in the
cloud morning ok ok so I'll build up to
this but I won't quite prove the entire
thing but but almost so to warm up just
to warm up suppose we actually have a
row partition right so each of these AI
is a 1 a 2 0 on is a subset of rows and
you would like to do sell the same
problem find a tilde so that they are a
good low-rank approximation so then it's
easy right so what you do is you know
you are you have a subset of rows so you
compute think of it as a full matrix
even though you only have a few non 0
rows compute aj transpose aj this is now
just a d by d matrix right remember a is
n by d ETA i is potentially n by d so a
transpose is d by n a transpose a or aj
transpose DJ is only d by d so everybody
computes there aj transpose aj sends it
to one server ok then that server adds
it up and announces the top k
eigenvectors of this of the
matrix so the total communication we are
using is s times d squared because
everybody is sending a d square matrix
right D by D matrix and you add it up
now it's server computes the can compute
simply the best so you so you've
announced v top k eigenvectors of B send
that back to I mean announce it to all
of the servers the top k eigenvectors of
B are just D by K right there k
eigenvectors each of them is a d vector
so it's DK or sdk and now each server
computes its put the projection of its
subset of data on to this these K
vectors that's all this V V transpose
all it's doing is project a on to the
span of V and represent it in in the
basis v so that's it so this is not only
a profit this is a just optimal this is
this is finding the exact right answer
why because you know the span of a bit
more what is B be is just a a transpose
a transpose a you're finding the top k
eigenvectors of a transpose a which is
exactly what a sweetie should do so this
is just an exact algorithm so getting s
DS squared communication in the row
partition model is not hard at all
because you could just since you have
complete rules okay but now let's do it
with an arbitrary partition now to do
this with arbitrary partitions the main
tool is a limited independence random
projection just as in people use in the
streaming model some very useful tool
there but it gets you things that are
impossible in swimming over here so one
notion that's useful is that a matrix P
which will be the projection matrix
there exists these matrices of size D
over epsilon square times n so that if i
consider any vector so now this is not a
for each but it's for all vector X in R
to the day the norm the two norm of PA x
is approximately I mean the two norm of
a x is approximately preserved even off
when you apply p the advantage is that
PA is much smaller right a was n by d p
times a is only d over epsilon square by
D
okay so the idea will be let's just
first project and then use the previous
algorithm of compute for computing the
SVD on the projected matrices okay so
all we have to do is agree on a
projection which will do exactly as in
this framing model you pass along a seed
to everybody and the communication is
going to depend on the seed length now
the seed for this this kind of matrix
depends on how much independence you
need you only need d lies independence
so the seed length is d squared in fact
you need even less d squared so you pass
along d squared length seed everybody
computes a projection matrix locally
projects their subset of rows on to that
sense that all to one matrix which then
can compute the SVD or the rank a
subspace sense it back so here it is
agree on a projection matrix p by random
seed eat several computes p80 sends to
server 180s there subset of the matrix
it's an arbitrary row partition then all
right I mean arbitary partition each
server and 771 computes the total of all
of these so it's got PA server one has
managed to get the projection of the
entire matrix now it can compute the top
k single erectus of this and projects
and announces them once it announces
them everybody can do their own
projection onto the subspace so that's
the whole algorithm and now for this the
communication is same way as before s d
squared over epsilon squared and we get
a 1 plus epsilon approximation so we'll
see why should this be a good
approximation so we're saying if you
replace the matrix a by PA then the best
rank K approximation for PA is still a
good rank approximation for a that's the
only thing I have to prove okay after
that it's done because everything else
is saying that PA can be computed
efficiently in the cloud okay so why is
the best ranking approximation for PA a
good approximation for the rank a good
rank approximation for a so that that's
just I'll do the same algorithm I put it
up there and here is the proof so we
want to show that now remember V is this
best rank K vectors calculated for PA
that
the algorithm calculates so the error of
the projection calculated by the
algorithm is at most 1 plus order
epsilon times the best possible oh I met
you let this one pass or close your eyes
yeah okay hey that's supposed to be opt
there okay I maybe I can and now to be I
guess I have to be consistent okay okay
so that's the best pranky approximation
there it's going to show pretty good
yeah so extend so here's the proof it's
just two lines this is the part of the
first proof you will do extend v2 a
basis you know via member is only the
first K vectors right it's the best
friend k approximation of PA so it's k
back k orthogonal vectors extended to
basis we want to really now look at this
error well the error of a matrix upon
projection to a subspace as defined by
an orthogonal matrix V is the is the
projection onto its its its orthogonal
subspace so it's sum over k plus 1
through D of a VI squared now by the
property of the random projection each
length avi is preserved within 1 plus
epsilon and so this is within 1 plus
epsilon square of the error not the
error the the total norm of the
projection of PA onto onto these vectors
okay so that's one part this is just
saying that the error you got is in fact
at most 1 plus epsilon times the error
of the of PA of what of the optimal
value of the projected matrix now we
need to make sure that that value there
is comparable to the best possible for
the original matrix so that's the second
line so forget about the 1 plus epsilon
squared here there so this is the total
norm of PA when projected orthogonal to
the subspace we found well it's at most
what it would be if you project instead
of projecting you two to the vectors we
won through we case suppose we project
to the optimal vectors u 1 through UK
which are the SVD vectors of the matrix
8 which we don't know then that error
can only be higher and
yeah because V is optimal for PA and
then again we use the property that PA
approximately preserves norms within 1
plus epsilon so now you can go back to a
there and now a the projection of a on
to use is the optimal value by by
assumption so that's that's the a minus
AK there and we get a 1 plus epsilon to
the four which is one plus order of
epsilon okay yeah V is the stop k
singular vectors of PA
so the property of P is that it's
preserved for every length every effort
for the entire so it's a subspace and
Mary its preserved for the that's why we
need the D still in the picture here
yeah okay so now this last step I won't
tell you the details but we was SD
squared I promised us SDK and for that
we need to do one more thing which is
that instead of working with an N by D
matrix the problem with working with n
by D matrix is there is still this end
up here so what we'll do first is apply
a subspace embedding so that we preserve
the row space of the matrix so here's
the algorithm we agree on a k over
epsilon by n matrix S and a que hora
epsilon square by n matrix P ignoring
log factors each server computes s80 so
so it's now taking your data and
projecting it you know using this
embedding s so that you now are left
with only a k over epsilon by D matrix
on each server and you add it up and now
for this space SI for this matrix si
will compute an orthonormal basis of its
rose okay and send that over to
everybody so that now remember this this
this this essay is only KO or epsilon by
D so the orthonormal basis will have
length only Q is only has K over epsilon
vectors so now we project a to this
basis so a instead of n by D becomes n
by K over epsilon n by K over epsilon
and then apply the previous algorithm
once you've got an N by K over epsilon
matrix you can apply the previous
algorithm which take took time
s d squared the point is that by
applying the subspace projection up
front we don't lose the best the quality
of the bed of the best Frankie
approximation for this subspace is is is
within 1 plus epsilon of the optimum the
best ranking approximation after we
apply the projection later is within 1
plus epsilon now naively you might think
okay you have two different 1 plus
epsilon you're going to get 2 plus order
epsilon if you come at both errors but
it turns out that these projections are
orthogonal and so we'll be able to
actually keep it to just one plus
epsilon overall even though you are
doing to two of these projections
together okay the last thing which I'll
just summarize is clustering and by that
I really mean just k means clustering as
we saw in talk before the break so let's
talk there this is one of the things
that comes up were you computing centers
and you would like to find a clustering
that minimizes the distance is two
centers now one thing to note is that an
approximately optimal solution for this
problem can be very different from an
optimal solution in terms of how it
actually arrange its data and so one
thing we cannot do is just project the
data to preserve distances to a low
dimensional space and then cluster and
then optimize this function that just
doesn't work on the other hand kernan
and Kumar came up with this condition
that said that suppose you assume that
every pair of cluster centers are order
K standard deviations apart okay so
there is some structure on the data
where the centers are somewhat far apart
and what is the standard deviation well
the variance is the maximum over all
one-dimensional projections of the
average squared distance of a point to
its center now this this actually makes
sense in many contexts in particular for
Gaussian mixtures this is just the
maximum directional variance and what
they showed is that if you have a data
set for which you know the optimum
satisfies this condition then you can
find it and the algorithm is do an SVD
compute an approximately optimal set of
K centers and then run the k-means it
algorithm you actually run the k-means
iteration and that will give you a set
of centers that are very close to the
optimal ones close enough that the
clustering itself a grease on all
to all of the points okay so all I'm
going to say here is that you can do
this in the cloud if you assume a row
partition of the data and the extra step
we need besides the rank a projection
which I just covered is being able to
start with a good set of centers and for
that we use the result of Chen which
says that indeed to come to compute the
approximate good of centers or to
compute the value of a set of centers
you don't need to worry about the entire
data set there's a core set of small
size which you can use who which
approximates the value for every subset
of centers and this corset can be found
in a nimble way with low little
communications at the end of the day you
can do k-means clustering in the cloud
and achieve the same guarantee that they
get in their paper under these
conditions with only d squared plus k2
the for communication I'm not showing
the dependence on s but it's a
polynomial in s4 s equal to order one
service so it's the last thing so I mean
I guess that natural questions are can
you solve linear programs flow on
matching what is the communication
complexity of all of these things you
can ask this for any question NP what's
the communication complexity in the
cloud of for solving these things what
properties can you estimate efficiently
and then maybe there has been work I
mentioned some the other papers which
have looked at distributed learning a
random partition of data might be
interesting and maybe you can do much
more with a random partition of data I
don't know good result to tell you but
it's possible and it's also reasonable
and perhaps there's a connection to
property testing it's just a tentative
question at this point where these
parameters can be related so
so it's sub linear in M times n sub
linear in the entire yeah
error approximate solutions
so for example I don't know how to count
triangles accurately even if you have a
random partition yeah so it could help
because it's like a sample we are thanks
for what yes that's in streaming in the
streaming model counting triangles it's
they yeah so it's there in the masseuse
notes but also I think I'm its nodes
where you can you build this tripartite
graph right where you have a not
arbitral subclass the specific ones that
i pointed out so you can extend this
lower bound for four triangles see force
krrs so some including some for which we
have the upper bound that's that was the
point
there is a lower bound you mean oh great
okay so if you want to find the upper
estimate estimate the size of the
matching to within 1 plus epsilon or
factor torso fact it was easy
matching itself
but to output the matching that is
already a linear number of edges right
I think there is a going to be a talk by
Sudipto where he shows how to do
matchings nicely with but but linear in
n not still in union thanks
you